SPEAKER 1: Hi everyone.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Ah, OK.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Hispanic Heritage
Month [SPANISH].
You guys are our kick-off act.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Without further ado, [SPANISH].
Kick it off.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 2: So I'm going to
ask questions in English.
And then we can
translate if needed.
ALEX GONZALEZ: OK, cool.
SPEAKER 2: You guys are between
two shows in the Bay Area
now for your Latino Power tour.
Can you talk about
how you came up
with the concept for
this tour, and what
Latino Power means to you?
ALEX GONZALEZ: Me?
Well, first of all, we're
just so excited to be on tour.
We love playing.
We've been doing this
for almost 30 years.
I know it's hard to believe.
But yeah.
It's been an amazing
ride, this band Mana.
We came for the first time
in 1983 to the United States
to play.
Just because we
thought it was logical
that there's a huge
Latino community,
and there would be people
interested in listening
to our music.
And thank god,
things really took
off, and from playing
small clubs now
to playing huge arenas
throughout the United States.
So when we kicked off this tour,
it started actually last year.
And it was called
"Cama Incendiada,"
which is our last
record that we released.
So we're promoting this record
throughout the United States,
Mexico, [SPEAKING SPANISH].
And then when we were
going to come back again
for the second leg--
you know, right now
the elections are just
right around the corner.
And so Fernando came up
with the concept and says,
you know what?
When we go back to
the United States,
we should do a tour that has,
first of all, that we should
celebrate the Latino community.
Because the Latino
community has given so much
to the economy of
the United States.
And we have people in politics.
And we have people in
Google doing amazing things.
And we have people in sports
and arts, et cetera, et cetera.
So we said on one hand, let's
celebrate the Latino community.
But on the other hand,
it's very important
that we tell the Latino
community to go out and vote.
And get registered.
Because your vote can
make a difference.
It doesn't matter what party.
But you can decide who's
going to be representing
your district, or who's
your county, or your
state in Washington,
or even pick the president
of the United States.
So it's so important
to go out and vote.
Register.
And we're doing
that specifically
for the Latino community.
Their voice is very powerful
here in the United States.
FHER OLVERA: Well, yeah.
The thing is we are a little
bit living in a history moment.
The Latin community has
more than [SPEAKING SPANISH]
They were slaves 150 years ago.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Show me your papers.
No?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
I got to talk about that,
you know?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Just a few hours to
go and vote so you
can get many years of bonanza
or good things, you know?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
On your recent album, on the
one that you're touring now,
I really liked the
song that you guys
perform of [SPEAKING SPANISH].
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 2: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 2: Can you speak
to those issues now?
The way Mexico lost
this ground historically
and then perhaps is now
either regaining it or not?
ALEX GONZALEZ: Well, what we've
said is that borders exist.
What can you do, right?
We don't have control over that.
But I think the great thing
about the United States
is that it's such
an amazing melting
pot of different cultures
and people coming
from all over the world.
And you look at a
company like Google.
You see so many people
from different parts
of the world working here,
everybody brainstorming
and bringing amazing
ideas to the table.
And what Fher has said
is very important.
More than ever,
this country needs
unity and to not be divided.
So with this song in
particular-- and what
we've been doing as
a band is that we've
been pushing for an immigration
reform for many, many years.
FHER OLVERA: 20 years.
ALEX GONZALEZ: And you
know, before, there
used to be like a
working program visa
that you can come to the
United States and work.
And it was a lot more easier
in the '60s and those days.
Because a lot of people
like to come and work here.
But they missed their
culture in another country.
So there has to be a way
that this can work out.
We've talked about also people
that have come into the country
illegally.
Well, yeah.
They did break a law.
You cannot enter a
country illegally.
But I would say
99% of the people
that come in here to the
United States are working.
And they're contributing
to the economy.
So what we've said is that
definitely there needs
to be an immigration reform.
They should get in line.
They should pay a fine-- or if
they're working for a company,
that company should pay a fine.
Because at least their
employees are working for them.
But that way, these
people are registered.
They pay a fine.
They get into line.
And they become
American citizens.
And you know, it's also a
national security issue.
We need to know who
these people are.
But you know, like Fher said,
there's all this commotion,
like all these people that are
here illegally are bad people.
You know?
And like I say, the majority
of people that are here
are working--
hard-working people,
having two or three jobs,
supporting a family--
two families.
You know?
So that's a little
bit the way we
feel about the whole
immigration thing.
FHER OLVERA: And we hear
so many sad histories.
When you go to a restaurant, for
example, and the Latin guys--
the head chef or
the waiters-- came.
And you say, where are you from?
Oh, I'm from
Zacatecas or Jalisco
or, I don't know,
Colombia or Guatemala.
And do you have kids?
Yeah.
How many?
Three.
Where they at?
They are in Guatemala.
So you didn't see often?
No.
No in 10 years.
So can you believe that story?
It's something where
we travel as a band,
and we leave our kids just
for three weeks or four weeks,
your heart [INAUDIBLE].
You know?
Sad.
Can you imagine all
those histories?
So what we were saying--
Alex and me and the band--
why not do a reform like they
used to do in the last century,
in the '40s?
ALEX GONZALEZ: Yeah.
FHER OLVERA: The people came
here, worked for several months
or whatever.
And go back.
And as a Mexican citizen,
just temporary jobs.
So there are a lot
of things that people
can do in the reform, no?
I think it's going to be
perfect for the United States
to do that.
I don't know.
It's taking too long.
It's taking a lot
of sad hearts, a lot
of tears in many,
many Latin cases,
and many histories-- many.
Millions.
So what we're trying to tell
these guys who got the papers,
American papers--
choose the right people.
You know?
Now, another reflection that
I was talking with someone
in Google-- the moment
that you guys are doing,
and the moment that
we are leaving,
is also a break in the history.
500 years ago, in the century--
in the 1500s, in the year 15--
I think 40.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Remember?
The print?
It was the last technology.
So people started to get
books and read books.
Before that, it was so expensive
to buy a book and write hand,
because it would take so long.
So only the rich people,
the privileged people,
can have all this information.
And when the print came in
those days, the world changed.
In everyting-- in science, in
medicine, in art-- everything.
After that, everything
goes well-- television
and other things.
But then comes the Internet.
It was another break
in the history.
Because all people can get
the information fast, free,
most of the times, and
all over the world.
And they can work also
for change-- governments,
if the people want.
It's a tool.
Sometimes it's a dangerous tool.
But it's a tool, a great tool.
So what are you doing?
You are changing this part
of the history of this era
that we are living.
Because [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ: I still don't
know how they do it, man.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Magica.
ALEX GONZALEZ: It's scary, man.
It's spooky.
FHER OLVERA: Yeah.
It's scary.
ALEX GONZALEZ: Yeah,
we've got like--
FHER OLVERA: There
isn't Facetime.
ALEX GONZALEZ: I don't know.
It's insane.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 5: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 5: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ: Yeah.
It's really interesting.
Because we were
talking about how
in the '50s, the '60s and
'70s-- even early '80s--
to be a Latino, you would see
people that are almost ashamed.
They would talk in English.
And you would say
something in Spanish
and they wouldn't
answer you in Spanish.
It's like, it's great to
be an American citizen.
But it's so important also
to know where you come from.
It's so beautiful, you know?
Your heritage-- you know,
what part of the world you
come from.
So to be a Latino, or to be
from any part of the world,
you have to be
proud of your roots.
Be of course proud to
be an American citizen.
But you have to also
celebrate your roots.
That's such a beautiful thing.
I don't know why some
people freak out with that.
But it's great to
see, like we say,
the Latino community
in this case I
think throughout the years
has become more unified.
And that's important, you know?
Speak our voice and
also get the things
that we need as a community,
and work hard together.
And you know, I
think we'll continue
to grow and do positive things.
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
I think this story
of being afraid--
of on the one hand losing your
identity with immigration,
or on the other hand of losing
your identity as an immigrant.
This is not new
in the US, either.
I just heard a
story the other day
that apparently the
prohibition partly came
about because the Germans
and their beer gardens
and the Irish and
their saloons were
public display of culture that
was unacceptable at the time.
And that sort of caused
the whole prohibition.
ALEX GONZALEZ: Yeah.
Alcohol.
SPEAKER 2: You know, kids,
families all together
in the saloon?
You know, it's unacceptable.
And it seems like
the taco trucks now
are like the echo of that.
But do you see a tension
between identity on the one hand
and preserving some
kind of authenticity
and having a more
plural culture?
Do you think those two
things are opposed?
Or they can coexist?
Or what?
ALEX GONZALEZ: I mean, we've
seen both sides of the coin,
you know?
I think there's people
that provoke that tension.
And there's people
that celebrate culture.
So like I say, it's
kind of ridiculous
that in the 21st century we
have all this technology,
but on the other
hand, as human beings
we're still lacking
in so many things.
And I'm not generalizing.
But there are people
that are still racist.
There's people that
don't want other people
to come to this country.
You know, that does exist.
You know?
And that's the scary
thing-- why they don't want
to embrace different cultures.
But I think that the
majority of people
have a positive attitude.
The majority of
people want unity.
And the majority of people
want to work together
to construct this country,
to build it, make it better.
But it all depends on
people coming together.
And I mean, as a band,
this is a good example.
We've been together
for 30 years.
And we have our differences.
But at the same time,
we're very together.
And we work out things.
And we sit down and
we have communication.
And if one guy wants to
do one thing musically
and the other guy wants
to do another thing,
we try to find common ground.
But we work together as a unit.
And we have a mission
and we have a target.
I think people need
to once in awhile just
settle down and be a
little bit more neutral.
Yeah.
Coexist.
FHER OLVERA:
[SPEAKING SPANISH] for me.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
Welcome, All-American community.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX GONZALEZ: They
got everything,
but the tequila
part was perfect.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
You got that?
Can I say that in English?
OK.
What I was saying is that
it's really important
having Google that you can
search anything you want.
And now with the elections,
we're telling the voters, go.
Search.
Educate yourself.
Find out.
And even though it's a tool, it
can be also a dangerous tool.
Because sometimes people write
things that are not true.
So the more you investigate,
the more you know.
Knowledge is everything.
Knowledge is power.
And so we're telling
people to really,
really be hands on
and investigate.
And then you decide
for yourself.
But you know, it's just amazing.
Yesterday I was with my
daughters and my wife.
And we went to take a
really nice trip on the Bay.
We went to the
Golden Gate Bridge.
And we saw it on top and we
saw it underneath and stuff.
And one of my daughters asked
me, hey, when was it built,
and all this.
And you know what?
I told her, go to our
friend Google and search it.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm serious.
Every time, [INAUDIBLE]
oh, let's call Google.
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 5: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
What issues do you think that
the Latino community in Google
should keep top of mind,
or what should Google
be keeping top of
mind, about the Latino
and Hispanic communities
specifically?
What can we do in that area?
ALEX GONZALEZ: Well, I think
one of the things that Google
can do is go out to
the streets, you know?
And see for yourselves.
And investigate.
And ask questions.
You know, I think it's
good to be curious
and to ask questions.
And why this?
And why that?
And ask, you know?
Because everybody has their own
issues and their own problems,
and also their positive things.
But it's so important to go
out there and investigate.
And when you're hands on like
that, you know what people want
or what people need or
what their thoughts are.
And then I think
that will definitely
help you guys to
build better platforms
or to build better
communications.
You know?
There's just so much
that needs to be done.
But I think everything has
to start with one's self.
You know?
You can be a better
person if you want.
You can take care of the
environment if you want.
But it all depends on yourself.
You start first, and then
obviously with the community.
So I think that would be
an interesting thing--
to go out and just
ask questions.
And go all over the area.
And see what ticks people
off or what they like
or what they would
like to see changed.
SPEAKER 2: So I'm
hearing more user
research, more ethnography.
FHER OLVERA: We've got a
[INAUDIBLE] foundation--
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
So I think Google and
people [SPEAKING SPANISH]
Just for a few years,
and then you leave.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
So you can mess around
with this house.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
If you want something
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX GONZALEZ: Oh here we go.
OK.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
number four [SPEAKING SPANISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
human rights [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 5: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
It's their fault.
They are corrupt.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
Red, [SPANISH]
stop, you have to.
[SPANISH] otherwise
[SPANISH] your car.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
There's good news.
We're gonna be playing Oakland.
[CHEERS]
In November.
So we hope you guys
go and check us out.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
AUDIENCE: Oh my gosh.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
ALEX GONZALEZ: (CHANTING)
Juan, Juan, Juan!
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
JUAN CALLEROS:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
JUAN CALLEROS:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FHER OLVERA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER 5: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER 2: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ALEX GONZALEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]